[Music]
all right so let's shift to your new
book living with the monks I want to get
the the subtitle totally right here cuz
I love it
what turning off my phone taught me
about happiness gratitude and focus so
we are taping this right now we're
holding it for a little bit because I
want to air this right before I go off
the grid cuz my audience knows I do this
August off the grid thing literally lock
my phone and is safe no phone no TV no
electronics no nothing I'm gonna work on
my book a little bit I'll probably
escape to a beach for a little bit I'm
not even totally sure what I'm gonna do
but just get off the endless information
grid so before we talk about me and why
I think it's good to do that what led
you to wanting to do this at first place
well I'd spent I'd invested so much in
the physical side for my whole life you
know running marathons and doing
endurance events and had a Navy SEAL
move in with me but I really had felt
like I had neglected the inner side and
just the inner work and I was just going
so fast so I felt - really again maybe
I'm turning older I don't know but to
get the whole package
or that what I want it and be is
well-rounded I really needed that side
it's the spiritual side and and I was
just thinking like well who would be the
best teacher and I thought monks and I
didn't know anything about monks other
than like watching some movies right
you know fringe articles here and there
I thought that'd be really cool to learn
about you know the traditions and how
monks lived their lives and doing
exactly what you said you know I'm I'm
bombarded by information mm-hmm and I
don't spend any time alone and when you
don't spend time alone you lose your
superpower you use your intuition
because you're being influenced by
everybody else and you exercise your gut
muscle I was losing my superpower
so I said to Sara I think I want to go
and was there a moment that you really
felt that you had lost it or that you
could really recognize that you lost it
cause I think a lot of people walk
around with that all the time now I
stopped just cuz the endless social
media you're so hit with stuff
constantly that
does make your your sort of inner
monologue sort of harder to listen to
because it's just being slammed in every
which direct it wasn't buildup I just
felt so distracted yeah and you know we
all feel overwhelmed I mean but I felt
really distracted and I felt like you
know four kids a job I married friends
my parents are getting older I mean all
these different things and then all
these different social media things and
news and Netflix and Hulu a little bit
of like I just want to like I got I
would just be alone and so was it
build-up and then I mean my wife and I
were talking about it and so they just
wanted I'm gonna go and live on a
monastery and she was super encouraging
you know and she was like so so that's
what happened so what do you do you give
a call you yelling yelling yeah yes
sirree no I am I actually found this
monastery through a friend of mine who's
actually my publisher and I went to a
monastery with eight monks which already
was a misconception for me because I
thought monastery meant community meant
hundreds but there were eight monks at
this particular monastery for which have
been there for 50 years Wow and they
lived on 500 acres in the States but in
isolation 500 acres and similar to what
you're about to do in August or now yeah
you know no phone no internet no news no
this no that and I just took 15 days to
decompress so what was it like so you
get there day one I mean what was the
most shocking part I got since you're a
pretty open guy so there was probably
not much that could shock you but like
what do they say do they like take all
your stuff like first of all they were
Russian Orthodox they weren't Buddhists
okay so like that arete I didn't I had
no expectation of anything and I walked
into my room which they call cell that's
the rooms are called self and monastery
look and it was the size of this carpet
like where we are and I had a bed one
little desk with a light and brother
Christopher who was like my go-to monk
sat me down and he's
tomorrow at 7 a.m. we'll start with
prayer reflection and meditation and I
said ok it's 6 p.m. yeah what do I do
13 hours and he looked at me and he said
you think and I said ok and he left the
room and I realized like I can't call my
wife I can't there's no books in my room
I mean they had books but there are no
books there's no like it's super like
eerie quiet yeah and I'm like alright
I'm gonna I'm gonna meditate let me
start the journey
I took a TM Transcendental Meditation
course mm-hmm set my timer for 20
minutes I sat in my chair and I started
to close my eyes focused on my mantra
and I'm getting bombarded oh boy how are
my kids my wife you know the Hawks are
gonna what are we gonna do this yeah
everything in my head and we will talk
about the Hawks we're down by the way
I'm sitting I'm going I'm like why isn't
my beeper beep because I've been here
forever yeah and I'm like I probably
just started so I let me just keep going
keep going and finally there's no beep
and I said well let me just reset my
beeper and I'll start over no I go back
that would be cheating anyway I'm in my
chair forever and I finally like this is
ridiculous I'll just let me reset this
and start this again I open up my eyes I
look at my timer 3 minutes and 27
seconds Wow
and I not only calculated how many
minutes I had left on the monastery like
that 15 days times 24 times and I was
like I just said to myself I'm [ __ ]
like this is this is great on paper yeah
in theory but this gonna be [ __ ] hard
yeah and I just sat in my room and I was
like oh my god what'd I get myself into
were you allowed to leave the room I
could leave the room I couldn't leave
the property this is the craziest
situation so huh
the monks to keep the lights on at the
monastery they breed German Shepherds so
there are 11 adult German Shepherds 8
monks and me so they're selling German
Shepherds yes they sell puppies yeah
that's any trained dogs their world
renowned dog trainers world they've
written books they're sold millions of
copies of books they're just it's just a
really unusual scenario so yes I can
leave my cell yeah
and walk around the monastery but first
of all it's four degrees outside it's
there's no lights it's like pitch dark
at four o'clock right it's freezing
there's bear according to the monks like
so no I really couldn't leave them right
so I mean I just kind of like I ended up
walking 120 miles up and down the
driveway they had because I had to get
some exercise over the course of my
journey but I leave mm-hmm so I just sat
there and you know the first five this
five days was really really difficult
for me and I started immediately doing
probably what I think most people do
certainly what I do I started giving
myself an out I started justifying that
it would be okay to go home early mm-hmm
just seven days man that's enough get
out of here in seven days no one's gonna
say oh you didn't do whatever just and I
started creating all these excuses in my
head and I started thinking myself like
what are the goals do I have in areas of
my life and my giving excuses in you
know and really started like analyze
everything that was going through my
head and put it into out the the real my
real world yeah and I just saw a lot of
things about myself you know through
that through just being quiet and alone
how did you break through that moment of
if I can get away with seven days here
like what was the actual thing that
turned in on it I have a to words that
changed my life that I refer back to all
the time and though when I wanted to go
home those two words were like I signed
up fifteen days that's what that's what
this goal was 15 days day five when I
really want to go home and I missed my
kids and I couldn't call you know the
two words are remembered tomorrow when
you have this big split-second decision
or a big major decision how how is that
decision gonna make you feel tomorrow so
I said to myself if I drop out and quit
now the one time
I'm gonna do this in my life how am I
gonna feel about this tomorrow when I
get home when someone says how'd you do
did you make it terrible you know my
legs are swollen at Mile 18 I want to
drop out of the race or the marathon but
I want to come home the next day after
the New York Marathon did you finish
so remember tomorrow yeah so I just kind
of said that to myself over and over
like just remember how you gonna feel
about this and remember how proud you're
gonna feel at the end of the journey and
before I went my wife said don't leave
until you have a breakthrough you're
broken and I'm like I'm not broken and I
haven't had a breakthrough
I'm saying so did you get broken or have
a breakthrough you know it's funny
Hector I know the answer at least a
while I had some breakthroughs for sure
but I never felt broken and I think I
think the reason I never felt broken is
because it had a definitive end date
yeah so broken for you would have been
like I'm leaving okay like yeah it would
had to really take me to a place of you
know yeah yeah I mean I had moments of
being broken and super sad I mean you
know like when you're away from
everything and you don't know what's
going on you just don't know you don't
know God on my kids getting bullied is
something happening is my wife okay you
know is the world in risk is you just
don't know girl and you start to imagine
that the world's gonna head I think your
brain automatically goes to the worst it
doesn't go to everything it's great it's
like oh [ __ ] I should have been so much
nicer to my wife because I'm gonna go
there she's not gonna be home when I get
home yeah like you start sticking [ __ ]
like that yeah and then you spirals
because you have energy and space to
think and imagine and dream and a vision
and all the [ __ ] that's like it all
comes to the surface and you know
because it's in the real world if you're
having a tough day you could say to Dave
you you you guys good you know what
let's put on movie in Netflix and just
so [ __ ] escape and sit down you order
Chinese food and you have your Netflix
and your watch but guess what
the issues don't go away mm-hmm when the
movies over
[ __ ] is still there your to-do list
they're still there when I'm watching
that right they're still there yeah and
you know this forced you there was no
escape mm-hmm
this was your escape so it forced me to
have to think through stuff and I got a
lot of clarity you know it's funny
although this is in no way comparable
when I did my off-the-grid thing last
year and if for a week we were ten days
or so we were in Mexico and I just I
just needed to do nothing I just needed
to wake up every morning have a light
breakfast I went to the gym and then I
would just sit I got the same seat at
the beach every day and I would just sit
and stare at the ocean for hours really
for hours and I do a little try to do a
little meditation and stuff but I did
have that moment at one point where I
was like anything could be happening
right now like World War three could be
starting there you know the terror
attacked like but you know zombie
apocalypse like where you go to like the
craziest [ __ ] and then I remember
thinking I was like you know you go
there for a while and then I suddenly
got to the end of it and I was like well
nothing I could do about it right now so
I better reset to this better place and
there's a real discipline in that in how
you can control your mind and your
thoughts
I think the for sure the first three or
four days there I was obsessed with my
to-do list and by day four or five I'm
like if a hurricane came and whisked my
to-do list into the ocean life goes on
like okay yeah and you know I was I was
like a captive to my to-do list because
you know I'm always and it's my to-do
list for me wasn't even about finishing
that the tasks as good as I could
possibly do them it was about finishing
him so I could keep it felt so good to
cross him off that even if it was 70% to
what I could probably do it on to the
next on to the next on to the next at
the monastery the mostly to-do list
there was no to-do list mm-hmm it was
whatever is in front of me yeah is my
task at hand so tell me a little bit
just sort of what that day looks like so
you get up the next morning now it's
it's day two so Dave said did you say
7:00 a.m. or 6 a.m. 7 a.m. and then
prayer start yes so they would ring a
big a big like noted Notre Dame you know
church now loud
I was right next to which was the which
signal to go to the to the church where
they would have a about an
hour-and-a-half service which was
meditation reflection service what was
it religious in anyway yeah they were
Russian Orthodox yeah it was it was a
religion it was religious for me it was
it was peaceful but it was definitely
definitely religious and then and then
we would shift to breakfast which was
traditionally silent most of those
breakfast the breakfast were silent and
that would go to let's say 9:30 or 10:00
and afterwards there'd be a little bit
of a long time and then it would go to
tasks and each of the monks would have a
different responsibility which was just
unbelievably efficient and I spent each
day shadowing a different monk so I got
two rounds basically and then there
would be supper dinner was lunch time so
they flip-flop so breakfast was a really
light meal which for me is just fruit
then lunch their lunch was dinners that
would be the big meal mm-hmm rest well
it's like sleepaway camp you go that's
rest time we'll see if they're more
labor
yeah which could be cleaning the church
doing some whatever the everyone's tasks
were yeah they always have stuff to do
cause it's like it's kind of funny like
if you think about it like all right so
eight guys living at this place we're
always doing stuff oh it seems like
there wouldn't be that much more to do
you know because you don't want to know
why if the toilet breaks they don't call
plumber yeah I fixed the toilet they
built the monastery by hand they
everything is they do everything right
well let's let's get a swimming pool
okay get a shovel you get a shovel you
get a shovel
you know let's figure out how to do it
you know and we'll build a shovel this
wonderful piece so they do I everybody
hire you for a couple job and then and
then we would there was just more time
alone so there was a tremendous amount
of time yeah but also from a lot of work
so talk a little bit about the
disconnecting from technology I get the
concerns about your wife your kids
things like that how did you feel about
not
putting your hand in your pocket to go
to your phone or not having an iPad
right in front of you or television
screen or the rest of it you know it's
funny because when I got back everybody
asked me well would you miss and the
obvious answer is I miss my family and
this and that but no one ever asked me
what didn't you miss and when I didn't
miss at all were things that I do every
day that I thought I would miss for
example I went during the NCAA
tournament I didn't miss not watching
March Madness vina something I loved to
do forever and if I calculated how many
hours of basketball I've watched yeah
that's like you know five years of my
life but I didn't miss it and I didn't
miss hitting like that you know liking
my friends picture in Cancun with with
you know they did with a corona yeah I
didn't miss any of that stuff I didn't
miss going through Hulu and Netflix and
debating with my wife what to watch and
I realized I spent a lot of time on
things that I really didn't miss and if
I eliminated some of those I would freed
up a lot more time to spend to do the
things I love to do with people I love
to do them with yeah so but it was it's
a reading of so comfortable with my
phone's always in my hand it was hard
man really hard it took it took a long
time to get to ask that did you feel
that there was like a little bit of a
learning curve with it like when I did
it and as I said I locked my phone and a
safe I did not know the code and I found
that for the first day or two I kept
going in my pocket even at the beach
like I'm just going to but there's
nothing in my pocket I don't think my
shirts had pocket so I was just like
going like this and then there's like
this weird anxiety of like what's going
on what did I miss is the zombie
apocalypse or the war started or
whatever and then suddenly by day like
five I kind of felt empowered by day
eight I was like I want nothing to do
with that then maybe there's a little
bit of like a return to I it'll be okay
I'll manage it differently did you go
through all of those steps the exact
steps you just mentioned in the exact
timeframe you just yeah once I got to
the point where I didn't miss it where
the habit of checking before I went to
bed or waking up at 5:00 in the morning
and seeing anything new come in through
you know the werner's once I got past
that yeah I just I didn't miss it I
didn't want
you know and once I got home and I put
on the news and read you know like
what's going on in the world and all the
negative stuff it was just like uh but
Here I am I've been home and I'm back on
my phone I came home I'm like I'm off
email right and then you know but you
drift back so have you been able to put
any kind of just personal policies in
place to manage this stuff because I'm
still trying I don't do phone in bedroom
90% of the night yeah every now and
again it's just somehow ends up there
but like that's one for me so that at
5:00 a.m. I just don't do that yeah I'm
at 11 the obvious ones you know no not
not in the bedroom not at Meal Time not
at movies I'm at I used to sit in movies
and I heard a ding or a beep or a buzz
yeah I go into my shirt and look it
doesn't like you know I look under here
but now so there's so I became misfit I
think this will summarize my experience
the best they had a retreat at the
monastery I made all these guests and
when the guests left they said to me
Jesse you're gonna clean up all the
dishes like the like the rookie on the
team okay
there's 500 dishes stacked so I started
cleaning the dishes I'm drying I'm
cleaning up and drying them and they go
and they bring more in and I turned him
I'm like I'm this gonna take me forever
how am I gonna do all these dishes and
one of the most certainly goes there's
not all those dishes there's only the
dish that's in your hand and I was like
it reminded me that I'm never where my
feet aren't and I gotta be where my feet
are you know this is what I'm doing yeah
there's something there because I do
find that I actually like doing the
dishes I know that's a little nuts and
I'm not doing it I'm not doing it for
500 people but I do find it's like one
of like I can't have my phone in my hand
while I'm doing the dishes right like I
it's one little thing that you're doing
right there
so I do find on these brief moments that
you know you know I'm on tour right now
and it's like when I'm doing this when I
have these brief moments I like doing
like very menial like I really like
gardening or just like cleaning up
outside or like these things that aren't
much because they seem to have this this
incredible importance we've lost touch
with a lot of those
things that help us feel connected you
know like we have no connection to our
food we go to a supermarket no unless
you live on a farm like we're very
disconnected from a lot of things that
make us tick and simple things like that
bring us back down to earth and then
around us and I felt the same way
I felt as a contributor even if it's
contributing to your own household you
know and as opposed to having someone to
come and clean it or however you guys do
it or whatever but it makes you feel
connected important part of it and it
creates momentum and wins I can't
explain it but I felt the same way I
loved it I was volunteering for it yeah
yeah there's real value in that like
even when you came into my house and
you're me like oh it's so great here and
it's not it's like I really love like we
put a lot of effort yeah it's like I
want to like wake up in the place that I
want to be at and like make it better
and make it more valuable all that so
for the average person that can't maybe
go take a month to do this well what's
the piece of advice or is it can people
do a weekend with monks can you do it
can you just do a day with bugs I mean I
think it listen I think I think anyone
can spend time alone yeah I think
spending time alone and you reckon I
recognize like I don't spend any time
alone other than going for runs which is
you know but I think it's really
important because I think the only way
you can really be in tune with your gut
is to be is to spend some time alone so
I think that's really important I think
for me I carry a lot of stuff in my head
I realized that I need to like I put
everything on paper now I get out of my
head it doesn't disappear but it frees
up space no I had a lot of space and
creative energy at the monastery because
I didn't have I wasn't cluttered so now
I have a two journal system that I use
it's very simple I dump everything into
one big journal doesn't go away but it's
out of my head yeah I don't want to
remember I forget a kid a birthday
present or whatever and then I make my
daily kind of routine and this kind of
thing and yeah I think just being really
aware of where your feet are is is
really important I mean the monks are
mano tasker's I live in a world of
multitasking yeah and I think that you
know for the everyday for everybody
I think that feels overwhelms or filled
that feels distracted is to do one thing
at a time and do it well and move on
have you been back to the monastery
since I'm going to go I have it back
what fun I'm going to go back to
partaking it or is it just like can you
go like just for some high fives
yeah I'm act like they're down for that
sort of thing like yeah yeah for some
high five I guess you'll find out I mean
I was like an alien yeah I came in there
I was full energy I'm like uh like what
are we running did they have any idea of
your history or just that you know that
your success is any of that stuff they
just think it's just some guy yeah we're
landing in on this I remember that must
have been pretty cool in and of itself I
remember very clearly sitting down I was
telling about my journey I was talking
about coconut water and they all looked
at me and said what's coconut water I
was talking about the Atlanta Hawks and
one of them raised their hand said I
went to an Expos game Wow
in Montreal and I'm like that's baseball
yeah alright well further our last few
minutes let's talk about the Hawks for a
second and just oh you own a basketball
team which to me is as you know I love
basketball like that's like the greatest
thing on earth like if I would probably
stop doing all this to I would trade it
in toe in a basketball team well I'm not
the principal owner I'm yeah yeah and we
got a great group but for me living in
Atlanta as a basketball fan I was a
season ticket holder for years first and
then I was a consultant to the team so I
got to fall in love with the players the
coaching staff management first and now
to be part of the ownership group with
my wife and friends it's in a city that
I live in yeah in a team that I love
yeah it's like you know it's just it's
just unbelievable is I was talking to my
wife the other day I said you know for
my father and my family and my friends
and the city there's 80 plus games a
year where I could put the teet nights a
year I could put the TV on mmm think
about you as a Knick fan yeah multiply
it by 20 and just you know as and just
really love it so it's been super
exciting and I think we got a really
bright future so I'm looking forward to
to the next couple of years I know it
was a little before your time of own
the Hawks but how is Dominique Wilkins
not in the Hall of Fame and I love Niek
house that kind of the whole thing he
deserves to be he deserves to be he's a
not only a great basketball player but
he is in Atlanta he's you know he's just
a big part of the of the community so if
he's a part of the a does the play but
he's um he's at every game sorry I've
never seen him saying no to a photo or
an autograph ever never just he makes
people feel really good yeah and he's
very approachable yeah what are you guys
doing over there to just bring all of
the things that you've talked about here
into the game and make it fun and add
some of the other stuff that's not part
of the 48 minutes like you know the go
New York's go thing I think there's
several buckets there's the internal
bucket and Tony wrestlers the principal
owners done an amazing job of just we
have a new practice facility that's
state-of-the-art best probably one of
the best in the NBA we're renovating the
arena massive multi hundred million
dollar renovation that's going on now so
there's a whole there's like the
internal stuff and then there's the game
presentation there's so many layers game
presentation there's the actual
basketball side of it there's the nights
that the team doesn't play that the
arena is available we have a concert I
mean it's just there's so many layers of
it yeah but I think at the end of the
day to that enthusiasm and passion and
just bringing whatever you can to infuse
a culture of think of your emotional
connection to the next you taught you
the first thing you said to me when I
walked in you took me to 94 games yeah
you remember this I remember where I was
sitting for certain games you know what
you're eating every five years ago yeah
I don't remember what I ate last week
right exactly right you have no idea
there's just so much emotion and if we
could bring that same passion to the
community and marry that with the
Atlanta Hawks that's gonna be super
powerful and I think we can annoy well
as a man it's pretty clear you're
bringing that to your life every day
because this was just I mean this flew
by and it's like I could feel it we're
done that's it
that's it well you got to go do Rogen
down so I don't wanna I don't want to
steal all your brainpower and now you
got three more hours with Rogan I sense
you're gonna be up to it to the
challenge and you don't even drink
caffeine you just hopped up on coconut
water
I am potassium down but you don't even
need bananas anymore do you
why would you eat a banana at this point
I eat a lot of bananas you eat them I go
to well this man it's been it's been an
absolute pleasure I suspect we will
cross paths again perhaps in Atlanta
because even though we're holding this
for a little bit maybe definitely come
watch you all right we're gonna come to
enjoy the Petersons abandon Atlanta
awesome for more on Jesse you can check
out Jesse its lair calm
[Music]